amigos argentinas no atraviesa por sus
mejores momentos
[Música]
a ver lo que es no tener para pagar nada
familiar no
el gobierno de mauricio macri ha tenido
que pedir un rescate al fondo
monetariointernacional y lo cierto es
que durante las últimas décadas las
crisis las devaluaciones la inflación y
las suspensiones de pago han sido algo
habitual en la política y en la economía
argentina pues bien en todo este proceso
un planteamiento político del que seguro
todos habréis escuchado hablar ha tenido
una influencia casi absoluta el
peronismo
la pobreza cero
nosotros los peronistas somos el único
partido político vigente en la argentina
fundado por en general pero ahora bien
que es exactamente el peronismo como
surgió qué impacto ha tenido realmente y
cuál ha sido su influencia sobre la
argentina amigos lo vamos a ver aquí en
visual político en dos vídeos y en este
primero nos vamos a centrar en sus
orígenes y en su identidad atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
quien fue juan domingo perón y lo más
importante como logró hacerse con el
poder e influir en la política argentina
durante las siguientes siete décadas
amigos para arrancar esta historia
tenemos que remontarnos hasta los años
30 del siglo 20 en aquel momento el
nacionalismo argentino vivía una época
dorada
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la argentina era sin duda la gran
potencia de latinoamérica a pesar de la
crisis del 29 continuaba siendo uno de
los 10 países más ricos del mundo y los
salarios eran mucho muchísimos más altos
que en la vieja europa
[Música]
sin embargo espera un momento porque a
pesar de ello la crisis del 29 había
hecho mella la crisis había afectado
duramente a este país y en medio de toda
la tensión causada en 1930 se produjo el
primer golpe militar un golpe apoyado
por muchos sectores políticos económicos
y sociales sobre todo del lado
conservador
[Música]
precisamente bajo todo este panorama de
militarismo autoritarismo y nacionalismo
era habitual que muchos oficiales del
ejército argentino fueran enviados a
alemania y a italia para realizar cursos
de perfeccionamiento
y amigos sabéis quién fue uno de estos
oficiales exacto juan domingo perón que
fue destinado a italia país en el que
pudo conocer y estudiar de primera mano
cómo está organizado el gobierno de
benito mussolini y sabéis que poco
tiempo después tendría la oportunidad de
poner en práctica estos conocimientos
a comienzos de la década de los 40
argentina estaba bajo el control de un
gobierno corrupto y autoritario un
gobierno que había perpetrado un fraude
electoral y que pretendía mantenerse en
el poder a toda costa
en estas circunstancias el día 4 de
junio de 1943 un grupo de jóvenes
oficiales del ejército argentino dieron
un golpe de estado supuestamente con el
objetivo de restaurar un sistema
electoral transparente uno de estos
oficiales fue el teniente coronel juan
domingo perón
[Música]
por cierto tras el de 1930 este fue el
segundo golpe de estado que sufría
argentina pero no penséis que fue el
último para nada durante los siguientes
30 años el país sufrió ni más ni menos
que cuatro golpes de estado más
el caso amigos es que fue precisamente
este golpe de estado el de 1943 el que
le abrió las puertas de la política y
del poder al teniente coronel juan
domingo perón prácticamente podemos
decir que aquí comenzó la historia
moderna de argentina atentos
[Música]
la jugada maestra
durante los dos años y medio que duró el
gobierno militar la carrera de perón fue
meteórica y eso que en un primer momento
tuvo cargos poco destacados cargos como
el de jefe del departamento de trabajo
un puesto que en principio era como
decir lo poco lustroso muy burocrático
sin embargo espera forma porque gracias
a su inteligencia política pero aún
consiguió que este puesto fuera todo un
trampolín para su ascenso al poder
veréis desde el primer momento juan
domingo perón aplicó todo lo aprendido
en la italia de benito mussolini y lo
primero de todo fue ganarse el apoyo de
algunos sindicatos
de esta forma cada vez que el
departamento de trabajo tenía que
intervenir en un conflicto entre los
empresarios y los sindicatos afines a
perón casi siempre los primeros los
empresarios tenían todas las de perder
como os podéis imaginar esto supuso que
la popularidad de este militar no parará
de crecer y crecer
el caso es que poco después pero fue
nombrado ministro de guerra y al tiempo
vicepresidente todo sin olvidarse de la
política laboral y de sus sindicatos y
es que amigos si algo tenía muy pero que
muy claro este teniente coronel es que
se iba a ser su trampolín político
[Música]
pero no era el único que aspiraba al
poder y tanto protagonismos levantó
muchos recelos de tal forma que en 1945
la cúpula militar le pidió que se
alejara del gobierno vamos que podríamos
pensar que la carrera política de este
militar llegaba a su fin verdad pues
amigos nada más lejos de la realidad
[Música]
había aprendido en europa la enorme
influencia que los medios de
comunicación podían tener así que le
pidió a sus superiores
ojo poder despedirse a través de la
cadena nacional de radio ingenuamente
aceptaron y perón no iba a desaprovechar
esa oportunidad en su mensaje de
despedida agradeció el apoyo que las
clases trabajadoras le habían prestado y
puso en duda la continuidad de los
beneficios sociales que él había
impulsado
y por qué
sobre lo mismo
para mí ahora
estoy al servicio espadas
y el efecto fue total los días
siguientes los sindicatos se movilizaron
en su favor y el 17 de octubre miles de
trabajadores ocuparon la plaza de mayo-
el centro neurálgico de la política
argentina
[Música]
el gobierno desorientado por cómo se
precipitaban los acontecimientos le
pidió al propio teniente coronel que
apaciguara el mismo a las masas cosa que
hizo pero sólo tras acordar con la
cúpula del ejército que sería cantidad
de las siguientes elecciones y que
contaría digamos con el apoyo
privilegiado de los poderes públicos
atentos
[Música]
y el asalto a los cielos
juan domingo perón había logrado ser
candidato ahora tenía que ganar unas
elecciones
pues veréis en aquel momento argentina
estaba bajo el control de los militares
de tal forma que para celebrar reuniones
se requería la autorización del gobierno
y los actos electorales no eran una
excepción
por supuesto los actos de campaña del
partido de perón eran casi
automáticamente autorizados mientras que
para sus oponentes en cambio bueno
digamos que el proceso era mucho pero
que mucho más lento y no sólo eso además
pero tuvo también acceso casi total al
medio de comunicación más importante del
momento la cadena de radio nacional que
era propiedad del gobierno
pero ahí no termina todo además el
gobierno a instancias de perón aprobó
las vacaciones pagadas para todos los
trabajadores así como un sueldo
adicional a fin de año no me digáis que
no son buenos reclamos electorales y aún
quedaba una jugada a la que esta especie
de genio de la estrategia política supo
sacar mucho partido fijaos
el departamento de estado de los
mismísimos eeuu intervino en las
campañas en favor de los rivales de
perón publicando un informe conocido
como el libro azul donde se daba cuenta
de la actividad tanto de perón como de
sus aliados militares en apoyo del
régimen nazi
sin embargo amigos pero aún consiguió
darle la vuelta al asunto y convertirlo
en algo así como una lucha entre el
mismo que supuestamente representaba la
soberanía argentina y los eeuu al final
con todas estas tácticas copiadas años
después por gobiernos populistas de toda
latinoamérica pero ganó las elecciones
el triunfo no fue arrollador pero se
hizo con la victoria y eso amigos era
suficiente
[Música]
el gobierno peronista
un dato muy importante cuando juan
domingo perón llegó al gobierno la
argentina estaba entre las 10 economías
más prósperas y ricas del mundo el país
incluso era un acreedor internacional
países como reino unido- le debían
dinero gracias a todo esto luego
presidente contó con recursos más que
suficientes para poner en marcha su
programa político programa que
sustentaba en tres pilares la soberanía
política la independencia económica y la
justicia social en la práctica lo que
hizo fue transformar argentina en una
especie de ejército a las órdenes de un
caudillo su presidente
como presidente perón nacional hizo un
montón de empresas especialmente las
vinculadas a los servicios públicos como
transporte energía y comunicaciones
además puso a la banca a bajo el control
del gobierno y aprobó un montón de
restricciones al comercio exterior
de esta forma pero logró un importante
apoyo popular como puedes manteniendo
las tarifas de los servicios públicos e
incluso por debajo de su coste y
contratando a un montón de empleados
para el gobierno y para las empresas del
gobierno qué casualidad los kirchner
hicieron prácticamente lo mismo por
supuesto todo esto implicaba mucho pero
que mucho gasto público y como pensáis
que lo financió 123 correcto dándole a
la máquina de imprimir billetes sí creo
que ya sabemos dónde comenzó la adicción
de los políticos argentinos por la
máquina conseguir billetes
el caso es que durante los primeros años
de todo este proceso gracias a todo el
dinero que se inyectó en la economía las
cosas parecían marchar viento en popa ya
toda vela el problema que simplemente no
era sostenible mientras el gobierno
gastaba a manos llenas la competitividad
del país empezó a hundirse más rápido
que el titanic en pocos años el saldo
positivo de la balanza comercial se
esfumó la inversión privada se vino
abajo y de repente algunos precios
comenzaron a dispararse
[Música]
y la pregunta es qué pensáis que pasó
creéis acaso que dado que su revolución
no parecía ir por buen camino perón
asumió algún porcentaje de culpa pues
para nada lo que hizo fue culpar a
supuestos especuladores de estar
atacando la economía nacional y para
remediarlo claro multiplicó los
controles los precios regulados y tomó
todo tipo de medidas que incluso
afectaron ojo a la distribución de pan
en argentina en el granero del mundo
guerra económica si la verdad es que
determinados discursos se repiten en el
tiempo una y otra vez pero amigos la
crisis no era el único problema al que
se enfrentaba pero la constitución de
1853 que era la que estaba vigente no
permitía que un político se perpetuará
en el poder
impedía la reelección inmediata y bajo
este panorama que pensáis que hizo
atentos
[Música]
la reforma política
junto a las máquinas de imprimir
billetes el segundo juguete favorito de
muchos políticos son las reformas
constituyentes y amigos pero no fue una
excepción
en 1949 como la anterior constitución le
imponía muchas trabas pero aún puso en
marcha una reforma constitucional
completa la nueva constitución situaba
al estado como pilar fundamental de la
sociedad argentina
incluso en el propio preámbulo de la
constitución se incluyeron los tres
pilares de las tesis políticas de juan
domingo perón vamos lo que se dice una
constitución para todos pero amigos si
queréis podemos echar un vistazo a los
resultados de todos estos cambios
la inversión se había esfumado los datos
macro cada vez eran peores el país
estaba en crisis y a las empresas
públicas argentinas les pasó lo que a
peu devesa no se invirtió en ellas
sufrieron enchufismos de todo tipo y al
final eran muy improductivas e
ineficientes para perjuicio de todos los
argentinos
en otras palabras el nuevo modelo
implantado por juan domingo perón se
convirtió en algo así como una máquina
de fabricar pobreza por supuesto todo
bajo un enorme culto al líder y también
a su esposa a evita perón el caso amigos
es que la sociedad argentina estaba en
crisis y tan fragmentada que bajo estas
circunstancias en septiembre de 1955 se
produjo un nuevo golpe de estado en esta
ocasión contra juan domingo perón
de personas asisten en la residencia
presidencial a la muestra tres
impresionantes con equipos de riquezas
naturales con el mandatario despuesto el
asombro de la música
falta por pertenecer estas riquezas a
quien basó sus políticas en el mundo de
la humildad y la pobreza ya en los
jardines se muestran ante nuestros ojos
su positivos automóviles y toma clase de
modelos de motocicletas y motonetas
vestidos sombreros zapatos y pieles que
no sabemos que habrán logrado reunir
ninguna reina de ningún país del mundo
perfiles que valen una fortuna reunidos
en cantidad sal como para formar un
museo y aquí están las joyas basadas en
más de 60 millones de pesos
ahora bien pensáis que esto significó el
fin del peronismo pues si es así estáis
muy pero que muy equivocados pero de
todo esto hablaremos en un siguiente
vídeo amigos si esta historia os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
like al vídeo y suscribiros aviso al
político si aún no lo habéis hecho por
cierto muchas gracias alejandro gómez
por toda la ayuda que nos ha prestado
para la confección de este vídeo y
también a todos los que nos apoyáis en
youtube y en patrón un saludo y hasta la
próxima
justicia social
[Música]